hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
what is all Burcham whose orientation
towards and relationship with the other
figures that we typically call
existentialist and which he himself in
the mythos tifus is going to identify as
existentialist or as existential he
distances himself quite explicitly from
most of them saying that the existential
czar doing something different than what
a philosophy of the of the absurd which
is what he is endorsing and articulating
would require there's not a complete
disjunction though in that both of them
are in fact engaging the absurd both of
them meaning Camus on one side and
perhaps Nietzsche and Heidegger with him
and all the other people that he lines
up as the existentialist who are you
know typically engaging in some sort of
escape on the other side so Camus was
going to criticize the existentialist
but if we want to talk about him in a
very broad sense as being part of the
existentialist movement that is
perfectly fine and makes sense and is
warranted provided we understand that he
means something a little bit more
restrictive
when he's distancing himself from the
existentialists now what is going on why
is he criticizing them in some respects
it's because he's quite close to them he
sees a not just a common thread but a
whole network of common threads uniting
them and one of the key aspects of that
is that the existentialist in the sense
that Camus is talking about do in fact
found or ground their thought upon an
encounter with the absurd whether they
do this in terms of writing philosophy
or in more literary ways of writing
plays short stories novels poetry they
are engaging with a universe that
doesn't line up with human beings in
which human beings can feel themselves
you might say at a loss or foreigners
within their own cosmos and so he's
going to talk about and in what he calls
an entire family of minds related by
their nostalgia but opposed by their
method or aims that have persisted in
blocking the Royal Road of reason and in
recovering the direct paths of truths
and he says here I assume these thoughts
to be known and to be lived whatever may
be or have been their ambitions all
started out from that indescribable
universe where contradiction and tena me
anguish or impotence reigns so the the
existentialist have a common starting
point as a matter of fact it's not just
the existentialist it would be others as
well he talks about phenomenologist like
who Cyril and Schaller he also talks
about a number of other people at
different points but he's focusing on
the existentialist and let's think about
some of these things so they are related
by their nostalgia nostalgia for what
nostalgia for what they never had human
beings have a nostalgia for a kind of
unity or coherence
experience and existence that has never
been the case we have this you might say
tragic or absurd if we're using the term
very loosely and not exactly in camel
sense drive to find meaning in things
and not just lowercase meaning but but
grand you know uppercase meaning but it
doesn't exist and every time we tell
ourselves that we've attained it or that
it's there on the horizon Camus says
we're actually unfortunately deluding
ourselves so the existentialist are in
this this family they they have
different methods or aims right but they
like he says they have persisted in
blocking the Royal Road of reason they
are not rationalists they are while
they're using the tool of reason they're
also being critical of it and it's
pretensions and he says recovering the
direct paths of truth existentialism
just as much as the philosophy of the
absurd focuses on concrete existence on
real-life situations and on you know
relations between human beings to
elucidate the the truths or the
experiences or the essences even out of
them
now Camus is going to say a little bit
later in the text that the existential
attitude is a form of philosophical
suicide what does that mean why is he
claiming that well it all has to do with
the relationship to the absurd Camus
thinks that many of the existentialist
while they are beginning from the absurd
like him as a starting point they're not
remaining with the absurd in the way
that Camus is advocating in his
philosophy of the absurd he's saying
that we have to take on the absurd
realize that it's there realize that it
pervades all of our existence that we
can never get rid of it and that we also
cannot come to terms with it
what is accusing the existentialist of
doing is you might say defaming the
absurd domesticating it turning it into
something that works for them in one way
or another and thereby either making
some sort of escape or eliciting hope or
engaging in some sort of leap that takes
them either directly into the absurd in
a way different than the philosophy of
the absurd or in effect beyond the
absurd and into something else in the
case of some of the existentialist like
for example Lev chef tov or certain
Kierkegaard into God likewise he says
for Dostoevsky and Kafka in their
stories in both the plot and the
characters expressing the author's point
of view which we'll get to in a moment
so this is a criticism he's saying that
they're in effect committing not
physical suicide but philosophical
suicide in that they're using their mind
they're using the absurd to get so far
and then they're doing something
different that amounts to shutting their
minds off no longer you know connecting
their their experience after the leap
with what went before the leap in his
work Camus is going to discuss the
existentialist at many different points
and I think that we can associate them
into three different groups maybe we
could say four as well because there's
also the group of existentialist who he
doesn't mention but definitely knows
about he and in that group would be
jean-paul Sartre who he briefly alludes
to as a author who who you know
identifies nausea who starts nausea was
written several years before the myth of
synthesis came out so it's very clear
that Camus has that in mind but he
doesn't reference art anymore after that
so what would these groups be the first
group would include yah Spurs chest off
notice that that you know in this work
that
Sisyphus chefs Toph is written with a CH
that's because of the French spelling
but it's really Sh either one is fine
Kierkegaard they they all fit into one
common group that Camus is going to
criticize another group would be the
more literary figures and you might be
surprised to see Kierkegaard in there
but Kierkegaard is in fact writing works
that are sort of on the cusp of
philosophy and literature so we have
Kafka Dostoevsky and Kierkegaard in that
group and then finally we have Heidegger
and Nietzsche being brought up as well
and Heidegger and Nietzsche make an
interesting pairing because Camus is is
not really criticizing them as such as a
matter of fact he seems to view what
they're doing as much closer to his
philosophy of the absurd than the other
people within the existentialist
movement or spectrum so let's take a
look at what he says about Heidegger
first he says Heidegger considers the
human condition coldly and announces
that existence is humiliated the only
reality is anxiety in the whole chain of
beings to the man lost in the world and
its diversions this anxiety is a brief
fleeting fear but if that fear becomes
conscious of itself it becomes anguish
the perpetual climate of the lucid man
in which existence is concentrated and
he goes on talking about this he says
that to conclude at the end of
Heidegger's analyses that the world can
no longer offer anything to the man
filled with anguish this anxiety seems
to him so much more important than all
the categories in the world that he
thinks and talks only of it he
enumerates it's aspect boredom when the
ordinary man strives to quash it terror
when the mind contemplates death he too
does not separate consciousness from the
absurd the consciousness of death is the
call of anxiety in existence then
delivers itself it's own summons through
the intermediary of conscience it is a
very voice of anguish it Jers as
existence to return from its loss than
the anonymous they so Camus is going to
conclude here that Heidegger stands in
this absurd world and points out its
ephemeral
character he seeks his way amid these
ruins that seems to be an endorsement of
Heidegger and his philosophy and his
position and at that point now come who
also mentions Nietzsche at a number of
different points throughout the work I'm
just going to bring up two that show you
that he seems to view Nietzsche in a
rather positive light in terms of this
criticism so he brings him up in in the
section absurd creation with philosophy
and fiction and he says that in this
regard with the regard of you know Bree
living with the absurd
learning it's lessons recovering their
flesh in this regard the absurd joy par
excellence is creation and he brings up
a quote from Nietzsche art
and nothing but art we have art in order
to not die of the truth so art provides
us or creativity provides us with one
way of addressing the absurd a bit later
he is going to bring up Nietzsche again
and he's going to tell us that here we
go
in this section on Kafka he says the
more exciting life is the more absurd is
the idea of losing it this is perhaps
the secret of that proud aridity felt in
Nietzsche's work aridity dryness sort of
the desert right in this connection he
says Nietzsche appears to be the only
artist to have derived the extreme
consequences of an aesthetic of the
absurd in as much as his final message
lies in a sterile and conquering
lucidity and an obstinate negation of
any supernatural consolation so it
appears that well you know Nietzsche and
Heidegger are not doing exactly the same
thing that come is and their viewpoint
on the universe is not exactly the same
as that of Camus that he views them as
much more closely aligned to what he's
advocating in this work the myth of
Sisyphus
let's turn now to the care the
characters in and the plots in Kafka
Dostoevsky and Kierkegaard he tells us
in a section on Dostoevsky that
Dostoevsky has characters who are indeed
absurd characters and and you can
imagine that if Dostoevsky had died
before writing The Brothers Karamazov
that Camus would have a very different
interpretation of him he talks about
Kiril off in the possessed of the play
by the way that that Camus put on while
it's a novel he adapted it into a play
Kiril off' is a very interesting
character we can think of others as well
and these are absurd characters he says
but what ends up happening says that
that the novel's like the Diary propound
the absurd question they establish logic
on to death exaltation dreadful freedom
the glory of the Tsar has become human
all as well everything is permitted
nothing as hateful these are absurd
judgments but what ends up happening is
that in The Brothers Karamazov Kyra lost
stavrogin and Ivan are defeated why
because Dostoevsky takes the same sort
of leap in his characters as the other
existential Tsar existentialist are
proposing in their philosophical works
right
so he says The Brothers Karamazov oft
replies to the possessed it is indeed a
conclusion Alyosha's case the le osha is
the young monk the brother of the car
the other car ma sauce is not ambiguous
right
Alyosha clearly says we shall meet again
there is no longer any question of
suicide and madness what is the use for
anyone who's sure of immortality and its
joys man exchanges his divinity for
happiness
so cow Moos point here as he says it's
not an absurd novelist addressing us but
an existential novel
what about Kafka again we could say if
Kafka now Kafka died leaving his novels
unfinished and it with instructions
actually to destroy them which is
literary executor max broad did not
follow but if Kafka had only written the
trial and his short stories common would
have a different viewpoint on him but he
writes another novel called the castle
and Camus is going to tell us that just
like these other existentialist figures
you know Kafka is posing the absurd he's
he's showing it to us in the trial but
then he's in effect taking it back in
the castle he says it would be
intelligent to consider as inevitable
the progression leading from the trial
to the castle Josef K the character of
the trial who's killed in the end like a
dog and the land surveyor K who's
constantly trying to get into this
castle are merely two poles that attract
Kafka and come whose point is again that
the the work of Kafka is going to be
existentialist insofar as the absurd is
being left beyond in the castle
Kierkegaard himself poses a really
interesting issue in part because
Kierkegaard has all of these different
pseudonyms and characters and is doing
something rather similar to what Kafka
and Dostoevsky are doing proposing
different ways of being through them
many of them are in fact in some respect
rooted in the absurd however the problem
is that Kierkegaard himself as the
author as the person articulating it is
carrying out this very explicit leap of
faith beyond and into the absurd you
know so for example in fear and
trembling Kierkegaard will have Abraham
and any other night of faith essentially
believing living acting by virtue of the
absurd which seems to be a de más
occasion of the absurd in this case when
we turned then to the this other group
Yas / chef stuff and Kierkegaard who he
discusses as a group very early on and
also in as representatives of the
existential a little bit later on he
views all three of them as exploring the
absurd realizing that in that you know
what it is that we take is having
definite meaning and grounding is
actually pretty groundless but then
going beyond that by virtue of that very
absurd so let's let's take a look at JA
Spurs for just a moment he says that yaa
Spurs despairs of any ontology because
he claims we've lost our naivete he
knows we can achieve nothing that will
transcend the fatal game of appearances
he knows the end of the mind is failure
but in that failure he's going to use
that to carry out this leap and to
thereby restore hope he says that he's
left powerless to realize the
transcendent and capable of plumbing the
depth of experience and conscious of
that universe upset by failure will he
advanced or at least draw the
conclusions from that failure no without
justification he as he says to himself
he suddenly asserts all at once the
transcendent the essence of experience
and the superhuman significance of life
when he writes does not the failure
reveal beyond any possible explanation
and interpretation not the absence but
the existence of transcendence and Camus
says nothing logically prepares this
reasoning I can call it a leap and this
is what he takes to be there in these
these existentialist philosophers like
EOS pers like chefs talk even more with
chefs Toth and even more so perhaps with
Kierkegaard an interesting reflection
given that by this time chef stuff had
written his book on Kierkegaard is
existential philosophy where he said
that Kierkegaard didn't go quite far
enough but this gives you a good under
standing of what it is that Camus is
criticizing in what he's calling
existentialist figures and why he would
want to distinguish himself from them
claiming that his philosophy of the
absurd beginning from the same starting
points continues on a different path of
reasoning that the existentialist
are ultimately abandoning
you